i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
alejandro que se te viene que ideas se
te viene a la cabeza cuando hablo de lo
incierto relacionándolo con la guerra de
malvinas
bueno que se te viene son muchas cosas
que se vuelcan en la mente del ser
humano
muy buena pregunta no está preparado les
aviso
pero
muchas cosas que
que a veces te dan bronca
pero en qué sentido que hablan los que
no saben lo que nosotros pasamos
que mejor que nosotros los veteranos de
guerra lo que gracias a dios y la virgen
estamos acá podemos decir lo que se
siente en un combate
es algo muy muy duro inimaginable a
veces porque no todos los días son
iguales todo cambia todo pasa y cada vez
con la edad se vuelve peor es como yo a
veces digo en mis conferencias a los
alumnos oa gente grande que ya yo tengo
59 años ya aparezco como el plomo fuerte
por fuera y blanco
fuerte por fuera y blando por dentro y
todavía me cuesta todavía me cuenta
allá cuando empezamos a reunirnos me
encontraste sobre una anécdota la cual
implicó la utilización de caños de pvc
para engañar a los soldados ingleses me
gustaría que nos cuentes más detalles
acerca de ellos
bueno por la base siempre se comienza a
yo soy del arma de ingenieros pertenecía
a la compañía ingenieros 9 tuvimos un
gran jefe el señor oscar mayor oscar
menor y ni lima ingeniero militar y
puerto interno intérprete para que
ustedes tengan idea lo que es
un señor que se dedica a interpretar
fotos es decir ahora se está utilizando
drones que son esos avioncitos que
vienen los sacan fotos hasta en el fondo
de la casa antiguamente en el año 82
eran aviones que a cierta altura todos
los días los tomaban fotos porque se
había modificaciones en el campo de
combate este señor tan experimentado en
eso por esa maravillosa inteligencia y
yo lo tenga siempre sobre la tierra
todavía existe
se le viene una idea muy muy grande que
nos salvó la vida a las 130 que
estábamos hay 130 soldados porque tanto
sea oficial como suboficial somos
soldados igual nada más que con una
distinción en ese momento
qué hizo este señor agarro dos caños de
pvc los pintó de negro esos peces común
que usamos en casa para un desagote los
colocó en la costa como si fueran
bacterias costera decir que apuntaban
hacia el mar nosotros estábamos
bombardeado constantemente para que
tengas una idea
desde que comenzó el conflicto del
primero de mayo hasta el último día
recibimos casi entre 2.800 y 2.900
disparos de cañón por esa simple obra
no tuvimos ninguna baja no tan sólo hizo
eso sino que también también agarró y
cortó tambores de 200 litros los puso en
la costa como si fueran radares
más técnicamente que hizo nosotros
éramos 130 a cada uno nos hizo hacer un
pozo de zorro más y lo que ustedes
llaman trinchera nosotros le llamamos
pozo de zorro donde el hombre vive
durante su periodo de combate así que
éramos por cada uno había cuatro de
pozos o ramas a todo esto el avión que
venía mañana tarde o noche y nos tomaba
fotos sí entonces después se llama como
un rompecabezas y se veían las distintas
diferencias que había en el terreno
en el en el combate para que te des una
idea para sacar un nombre dentro de un
pozo de zorro necesitas 3
así que aproximadamente nosotros para
ellos
éramos 720 para desembarcar eso en el
sector donde estaba yo que llamado baya
fox necesitaban redondeando 2.500
soldados no se arriesgaron a desembarcar
por la cantidad que éramos nosotros no
se arriesgaron a desembarcar por los
estos cañones simulados y si alguien del
público tiene alguna duda en google
tranquilamente dice regimiento que
engañó los ingleses con los cañones de
plástico hay gastar toda la historia
bien especificada de lo que hizo este
hombre cuando vino el día de la
rendición el comandante de la fragata
que los enviamos variando constantemente
sentado con mi jefe el ofreció servicios
de esa mirada o ejercicio no lo hacen
ninguna falta bueno pero escuché me dice
el señor dice con todo lo que le hemos
tirado ustedes no tienen ninguna baja
no tenemos ninguna baja estaba el jefe
de la artillería de ellos y se da vuelta
el comandante de la fragata le dice
cuánto dinero ha gastado la reina en
esto
a todo esto
es bueno presente me todos aquí todo su
equipo de combate que empezó a contar el
comandante 130 no dice acá falta gente
no les cerraban los números no les
cerraban los números como hicimos
comúnmente ya el inglés estaba loco
porque no le cerraban los números esto
es toda mi gente
pero son 130 sí pero yo conté 720 pozos
y nos engañamos es una historia que es
más el comandante de las fuerzas
terrestres general woodward cuando lo
que hizo venir a saludar a mi jefe
pero en una persona muy especial porque
cuando nos tocó levantar el campo minado
que habíamos dado para mayor seguridad
él también lo estaba cinto él lo estaba
haciendo un ejemplo de personas porque
como mente superior controla no ejecuta
él estaba la parte de nosotros y
suboficiales o el bar
y recalcar estos suboficiales y
oficiales levantando el campo minado y
ningún soldado era tarea de los
superiores
-alejandro de cómo te relacionas te con
la distancia de tus seres queridos
durante la guerra y con lo incierto de
no saber si vas a volver a verlos
bueno primero no existía el celular
está muy atado al tema de esa relación
yo te puedo asegurar que nuestro momento
de soledad
quieres reflexionar y te acordás de tu
mamá de tu papá del perro del gato
porque a ver por qué dice el mandado a
la vieja
muchacha que sentado a mi viejo y ahora
capaz que en esta vida la voy a pagar
te juro que te acordás de todo eso
siempre digo que todos tenemos un dios
todos en ese momento te puedo asegurar
flores en cualquier dios muere si no no
tengo ningún dios pero si siempre hay un
dios se hace un shulman la religión que
vos quieras poner pero siempre hay un
dios de por medio
también participaste como casco azul
durante la guerra de los balcanes que
fue la que terminó con la disolución del
país
en aquel momento llamado yugoslavia me
gustaría que nos cuenten un poco más qué
son los cascos azules y que te movilizó
a formar parte de ellos
bueno los cascos azules vendrían a ser
primero que yo fui la primera tanda acá
en el año 92
me note por voluntad muchos dicen pero
no te alcanzó una guerra para ir a otras
y capaz que sí capaz que no era tener
otra experiencia
y compartir con otros ejércitos otras
ideas otras formas de trabajar pero no
la cambio por la forma de trabajar
argentina puede tener la mejor
herramienta pero el corazón que tiene el
argentino es algo indescriptible la
misión del casco azul es trabajar como
un árbitro durante una guerra
digamos que trata de lo posible en lo
posible de que no se enfrenten en lo
posible como a veces también
le dan a las naciones amigas van armadas
hasta no no es que no vayan armar
naciones unidas para armadas por medidas
de seguridad
vuelvo a la guerra de malvinas y te
pregunto qué imagen recordadas es una
vez que volviste de la guerra y quien te
recibió en ese aumento
bueno yo estaba en una guarnición
militar sarmiento que está en chubut
entre medio del lago muster
nos recibió todos los camaradas y
compañeros que quedaron ahí más la gente
del barrio militar que estaban ahí para
el pueblo que estaba a ocho kilómetros
de ahí
es volver a ver a la gente y algunos te
abrazan a mis viejos son de buenos aires
yo estaba a dos mil kilómetros te
abrazan como si fueras el hijo el
hermano o que se yo cualquier cosa esos
abrazos que a veces son son
indescriptibles pero te rompen el
corazón
en el texto río de la plata' en 2012
miguel sabah otro ex combatiente de la
guerra malinas habla de la euforia
sobreviviente
las experimentadas que una vez que
volviste en la experimentadas hoy en día
también
mira yo creo que sobrevivientes serían
los del general belgrano
si yo siempre he tratado de comparar las
de ejército a la marina en que o fuerza
aérea yo tenía un lugar donde se pisaba
la tierra y estaba seguro atrás de una
piedra estaba seguro lamentablemente lo
de belgrano
[Música]
no tenía en donde pararse y salvarse o
esconderse o refugiarse lo mismo que un
piloto de avión no sé qué sensación será
viajar en un avión y que te estén
tirando y que te tires en paracaídas
caes en un mar que te puedes congelar
sino temores de una cosa temor y de otra
y si son muchas secuencias que te dan
todo lo que siempre repito no soy un
sobreviviente soy un agradecido de dios
que estás sobre la tierra
alejandro te consideras un ejemplo como
seguramente la mayoría de esta sala un
héroe
vamos vamos a saber diferenciar pero no
soy
y no me gusta por más que me documento
que me es un
un papel simple que no identifica a
nosotros que nos dice a los verdaderos
veteranos de guerra es combatiente héroe
de malvinas para mí héroes son lo que
quedaron allá
los que
perdón
[Aplausos]
[Música]
son los que
están en el mar y siempre no soy porque
soy un ser humano el ser humano tiene un
montón de errores
como todos
como dice una canción de nuestro rock
puede más la indiferencia de tu gente
que la bala más horas del enemigo
los excombatientes de guerras alrededor
del mundo suelen sufrir consecuencias
psicológicas post-guerra por eso tenemos
que ser consciente de ello
y brindarles nuestra ayuda y apoyo yo te
quiero agradecer a alejandro por estar
hoy con nosotros compartido esta
experiencia y haberlo hecho con tal
entereza
muchas gracias alejandro gracias a vos
[Aplausos]
[Música]